Allah likes those things which are
consistently and regular even if it is
small
consistent. So this is the acronym
Islamic better than the management gurus
who talk about
smart
and most of the management gurus they
give the
example of goal setting of Wilar
Rudolfph.
You may not have heard of Wilar
Rudolfph. Unless you're in the
management, you know the example of
Wilar Rudolfph. Who was Wilar
Rudolfph? Wilar
Rudolfph in the 1930s and
40s. She was a girl who
was born with
polio. In a young age, she had polio. So
the doctor said she was wearing braces
and the doctor said she cannot set her
foot on the ground. She will never be
able to walk in a full life. Young girl
few years old having the
braces. But a mother told
Wilma that whatever you
want you think you can do
it. Forget what the doctors say.
Whatever you
desire, you think about it and you'll
achieve it. So, Wilma says she wants to
become the fastest woman on the face of
the
earth. Imagine
polio having braces. Doctors say she
can't put foot on the ground and she
wants to become the fastest woman to
run. So, at the age of nine, she removes
the braces.
At the age of 13, she takes part in the
first
race and she comes out
last. Later on, she's
persistent. She's so much
persistent that in
1960 she takes part in
Olympics and she gets the gold medal in
100 m dash, 200 m and 400 m. She become
the first woman in the history of the
world who's
paralytic and she become the fastest
woman in the world not only in 100 m
also in 200 m also in 400 m she does a
world
record because the mother gave a
courage and she followed and if you
let's analyze let's analyze the
Islamic goal
setting that was the goal
S for the Islamic
Sharia not very
much. S is this specific? Yes, specific.
She wanted to be the fastest woman in
the
world. Lucrative. Yes. Lucrative for
this world. She'll get very
famous. Fastest woman in the world.
Lucrative. Very
lucrative in this world. Akira. No.
A was it apt apt for her in this dunya
but not
a was it measurable? It's measurable.
She knew the
timing. Who was the fastest woman
before? Whether 9 seconds plus or 10
second plus, whatever it is, it's
measurable. I intention. What was the
intention? Was it to please
Allah? I don't think so. Maybe she
wanted to be called the fastest woman in
the
world. C. Was she consistent? Yes, she
was consistent. She was
consistently fighting for her goal until
she achieved
it. Now if you compare this, it may not
be fully Islamic goal setting the way we
are doing.